(musical sting)
- All right everybody, I wanna finish up
with something pretty funny
I found on social media.
This is, "What I'm Liking".
♪ Intro music ♪
Just recently, a New York
woman was on a flight
to Florida when she noticed
a certain unpleasant scent
wafting in the air.
She wanted to figure out
where is was coming from.
So she put a message on
her phone and airdropped it
for anyone on the plane to see. Turns out,
most everyone on board was
asking the same question.
We have her on the line
right now, watching
on NBC 4 New York.
What's up Devin?
(applause)
- Hi Kelly!
- You are hilarious, so tell
us more about what happened.
- Well, okay, so as soon as I boarded
the plane and I got to
my seat. It- the dreaded
smell of farts filled
the air, just the worst.
So I- I typed out a note
on my phone, just saying
"If you're farting please stop"
And I sent it out through
Air Drop, just anybody
who had their phones unlocked could
receive it so I was just
tapping away, sending it out.
(Kelly laughing)
And almost immediately, you could start
to hear laughter erupt.
I heard people giggling in their seats,
and so I just kept sending
it out anonymously, because
my hope, Kelly, was that the culprit would
receive the message.
(laughing)
And then soon after my phone
started vibrating, and I was
getting Air Drops back!
So people were laughing,
trying to pinpoint
who did it, what aisle.
If that's you, cut it out.
Um, and now also on my
flight there were tablets
behind the seats that you
could play games with so
I ended up connecting with
people through the Air Drop
of, people who wanted to play games.
So, I ended up playing
three games of Battleship
which, a humble brag, I
won all three of my games.
(laughter and applause)
- I love you!
- This whole thing just
turned into a tablet
AirDrop party.
- I think that is incredible!
My favorite one was,
"Bro, it's aisle 16".
(Kelly laughing)
That's my favorite thing ever. So, you say
there's a lesson in
your experience, right?
- Yeah! I would say have
some compassion for your seat
neighbors. Planes are stuffy as it is, so
if you could go to the
restroom before you board.
Or just you know, relieve yourself but I-
I too have compassion,
I know that there's-
people have IBS or
whatever but it was quite
unbearable. I was pretty
nauseous, um, and I didn't
even send this out to be funny. I - I
genuinely sent it out
to solve the problem.
(Kelly laughing)
Um, but it turned into a
plane bonding experience.
So who knew that millions of other people
have related to this.
- Oh my god. I just
can't wait for everyone
to know your face and see you on planes
in the future. This is incredible.
Thank you so much Devin!
I am loving your post right now!
(applause)
And that's not all, our season long
partner Pilot Pen, makers
of friction the go-to
erasable pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those who take tough
situations and turn
them around. So they are
giving you $1,000, how does that sound?
(applause)
- Oh my god! Are you
serious? That's amazing!
- And also, congratulations
on the Battleship wins!
That is incredible. Thank you so much to
all our guests this hour: Julianne Hough,
Michael Carbonaro, and Danielle Kartes.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
try and change it!